نذهب لنستمع لكلمه رئيس الوزراء العراقي
في ذكرى مرور 20 عاما على الغزو الامريكي
مباشره
الذي يشهد هذه الايام لله الحمد
اقامه مثل هذه المؤتمرات
فقبل ايام كنا حاضرين في ملتقى السليمانيه
واليوم نتواجد هناك في هذا المؤتمر في
بغداد
وهذه علامه صحيه ومضيئه تدل على ان العراق
استعاد مكانته الطبيعيه
حاضنا للحوارات والمؤتمرات
والفعاليات بمختلف
مسمياته الحضور الكريم
نقف اليوم على اعتاب الذكرى العشرين
للسقوط النظام الديكتاتوري البغيض
مستذكرين الام شعبنا ومعاناته في تلك
السنين التي سادتها الحروب العباديه
والتخريب الممنهج
وعزلتنا عن مواكبه التطور والتقدم
حتى جاءت لحظه التغيير في عام 2003 وصار
شعب العراق صاحب القرار في رسم مستقبل
البلد
فتقاترت جموع العراقيين في سنه 2005 نحو
صناديق الاقتراع
بانتخابات نيابيه
تتحدى القذائف الصاروخيه التي كانت تتساقط
على مراكز الاقتراح
والهجمات الارهابيه الانتحاريه وهي تتربص
بهم عند كل ناصيه وزاويه
ثم بعدها بدات تحدي الاهم في السنه نفسها
وهو اختيار دستور دائم ينهي الحاله الشاذه
التي سار عليها النظام الديكتاتوري الذي
صاغ دستورا مؤقتا يوافق مزاجه من دون اي
اعتبار او مراعاه للحقوق الاساسيه لجموع
العراقيين
فاختار العراقيون في الخامسه عشر من تشرين
الاول عام 2005 دستورا دائما يؤسسوا
للمواطن
ويضمن كل الحريات
والاهم انه صار السقف الامن الذي يستظل به
العراقيون بعد ان عاشوا تحت ظلال الخوف
والقهر
لتزداد بعدها التحديات
والمخاطر حول التجربه العراقيه
بسبب الارهاب ونبدا مع هذا التحدي مرحله
قاسيه على ابناء شعبنا
فكانت مناظر الجثث الملقات في الشوارع
جراء القتل على الهويه مناظر غريبه على
العراقيين الذين تعايشوا بمئات السنين وهم
يتقبلون بعضهم بلا حساسيه او استنفار
طائفي او كراهيه عنصريه او قوميه
واستمرت بعدها مثل ما كنتم تشاهدون
وتسمعون موجات العنف الطائفي والعصابات
الاجراميه
وعمليات التهجير على الهويه ليصبح العراق
سوقا
لاخبار الموت والقصص المروعه
ثم جاءت صدمه احتلال تنظيم داعش الارهابي
لمناطق واسعه من محافظاتنا شمالا وغربا
حتى اذا ما طرقت ايادي الخطر ابواب بغداد
استنفر العراقيون جميعا بعد فتوى جهاد
الكفائي
ولملموا ما تشتت من شملهم وتزاحمت اكتافهم
على السواتر
ليسطروا اروع القصص عن شعب تجاوز الامه
وجراحه
اشرس معارك التاريخ لتحرير ارضه من اسوا
عصابه ارهابيه
واختلطت دماء العراقيين جميعا
وهب ابن الجنوب والوسط وانتخى ليدفع الضيم
عن اهله في نينوى وصلاح الدين والانبار
ثم بعد ان عبرنا تلك المحنه كانت اثار
التلكؤ واضحه واخذت الشكوى من سوء الاداره
وهدر الاموال بالتنامي حتى شهدنا الكثير
من علامات الصخر ازاء عدم قدره مؤسسات
الدوله على الاصلاح والقيام بواجباتها كما
هو مطلوب
وبعد مخاض عسير جاءت حكومتنا الحاليه بهذا
القدر من كلمه رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
شاه السوداني في مؤتمر حوار بغداد الدولي
بنسخته الخامسه في ذكرى مرور 20 عاما على
غزو العراق الى اللقاء